salut qu'à des biches qu'est ce qui se
passe on va bien très bien pourquoi
pourtant il ya un premier hommage à je
ne comprends pas casimir mais il n'y a
rien à comprendre
je te demande si tout va bien si si tu
vois quelque chose d'anormal du rac a
crié au secours très fort bon ben écoute
si tu voulais me rassurer tu as réussi
mais non je te demande de ne pas
inquiéter enfin casimir on ne dit pas
des choses comme ça sans raison si tu me
parle ainsi c'est qu'il ya un danger
mais je ne peux rien te dire mais il
faut que tu sois très courageuse il a
vraiment fini par m'effrayer qu'est ce
qui peut bien se passer
bonsoir bien bonjour kazemi est la leur
est grave
que se passe-t-il quasi mais j'ai essayé
de rassurer julie mais lyon caen 1 1 20e
julie a peur mais mais de quoi quasi
mais je ne peux rien dire mais tu
devrais y aller la voir alors je
traversais d'avoir prévenu
je vais tout de suite là d'avoir cassé
mire soit courageuse
c'est terrible je ne peux pas même pas
prévenir mes amis du danger qui les
menace
vous ne le répétez pas mais je suis un
agent secret en mission secrète
monsieur du snob marié voir à l'autre
bout de l'île
s'il n'y avait pas un énorme monstre
marin qui arrivait oui heureusement j'ai
pu rassurer julie alors tout va bien de
ce côté je ne vois rien tout à l'air
calme pour l'instant
le challenge est et espacées pour que j
ai peur c'est pas du tout dans son
caractère de s'inquiéter pour un rien
restons sur nos gardes c'est toi
françois julie vaincu ma fille et moi
aussi j'ai eu très peur j'ai le quartier
n'a rien vu bouger ou de julie de ce
côté c'est calme y'a rien
il ya des broches thon rouge est là-bas
tu tues tu en es sur julie oui et ça
bouge et j'en suis sûr ohlala des des
branches aussi haute
ça doit internet mal gigantesque à
tirano tahar htira nasa de ces monstres
préhistoriques terrible que les casimir
us avaient réussi à chasser l'île aux
enfants lisa des millions d'années c'est
sûrement ça au jury mais depuis ce temps
là on en a jamais revus sur la terre
brillante mais tu sais bien qu'il ya une
légende de casimir us ont dit il
reviendrait à jour mais c'est vrai tout
d'un coup je me souviens et bien si ce
jour est arrivé et julie ça va être
terrible pour nous tous oulala et dire
que les enfants de 5 ans le sont les
jouer encore un petit resto le temps
d'organiser notre défense nous autorise
alors s'il faut rester calme car en
votant pas vrai facteur vous avez réussi
à passer sur julie mais voilà un qui est
dedans seule couche pas
vous avez tous les deux des visages se
retourner que conduire qu'il est arrivé
une catastrophe est sacré r1
c'est justement le cas franchement
content de cela de votre bouche
je voulais les foyers tout à fait moi
facteurs oui vous souvenez vous de la
vieille légende aide et casimir us celle
qui annonce le retour des tyranneaux
genre tout juste acteurs tout juste
venir est venu m'alerter il est parti
combattre on remonte épouvantable ce
royaume
si vous l'aviez fekter il était d'un
calme et d'un courage c'était oui mais
les tyrannosaures vont revenir c'est du
projet des branches par là bas record à
la barre bon il faut que j'avais tout de
suite donné l alerte parlé ici cela
peut-être encore libres alors je vais
tâcher d'atteindre à la maison de
monsieur beauchesne à 4 soyez prudents
oui oui je serais pour une robe mac
terre j'espère qu'une nous verrons
d'encourager encore à chaque mot merci
françois maire ça on mais bon ami merci
oui il faut savoir se sacrifier pour que
vivent les nos enfants pour voir le
jeune acteur il est bien ce nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc nous avons mis les enfants à l'abri
c'est ce qu'alain l'impression que des
tyrannosaures nous observent premier
nous a été sous peu être dévoré déjà
casimir il facture non en tout cas tous
les deux ils ont fait preuve d'un grand
courage pour toi on dirait quelqu'un qui
vient là bas facteur facteurs quelle
joie de vous voir rageux je n'ai pas
voulu vous les sifflets ou s'avère si
j'ai prévenu monsieur beauchemin et je
suis revenu aussitôt j'ai eu la chance
puisque le chemin était encore libre sam
bien isolé maintenant oui bon c'est pas
tout faut organiser la défense du jardin
m'a semblé voir manger quelque chose
c'est ce buisson qui bouge mais je
n'avais jamais remarqué monfils en oui
la bouche et j'en suis sûr regarder au
cas et nous ouvre encore recherche
c'est sûrement les pièges méfions-nous
croyait rapion nous derrière le banc
[Musique]
au revoir
julie watson un miracle c'est du snap
vous êtes au courant de la situation
le tyrannosaure sont partout je ne peux
venir jusqu'à vous on me déguisant en
buisson faut que ça n'avait vu avant
j'aurais milles derrière mon bureau je
n'étais pas vu mais je voyais pas
beaucoup non plus je tiens l'information
de monsieur beauchamp mais c'est
terrible je n'en sais rien je vous avoue
que j'ai peur moi j'ai peur pour nous
tous c'est son corps mes amis oui oui
c'est comme si on voulait contrôler
derrière le but bonjour tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
casimir casimir que tu nous a fait peur
à l'ancienne mais quel joueur va revivre
monsieur dix neuf je suis bien content
vouloir je viens de l'autre bout de lire
et je n'ai pas vu un sarment stromae
mais par contre j'ai rencontré douze la
fin quatre moutons bien klein d'autres
amis une petite seconde
mes amis je crois que je commence à
comprendre la situation monsieur du
snack bar où étiez vous avez été alerté
par monsieur beauchesne de la venue des
tyrannosaures mais vous n'en avez pas
bien selon elle c'est exact facteur
c'est vous qui avait alerté monsieur
motion mais vous non plus vous n'avez
pas vu un seul tir 9 heures pour salon
françois bès c'est vous qui m'en avait
parlé
mais c'est vrai et tout ça parce que
casimir nous avez vrai monsieur du snam
envoyé en mission secrète et mes bébés
et tourner autour de moi je voulais m'en
débarrasser alors je lui dit d'aller
voir au bout de lui c'est même pas un
monstre marin qui débarquait j'aurais pu
tout aussi bien lui dire qu'on va voir
là bas si j'y suis quoi vous n'y étiez
pas non plus
dire que nous étions tous là à tremblay
peur julie thoune avait fermé côté je
t'avais bien dit de ne pas s'inquiéter
[Musique]